hi and welcome back to nintendo
treehouse live my name is kay and i'm
here with andrew and amber and we're
going to be taking a look at harvestella
andrew what have we got for people today
so today we're going to be taking a look
at chapter two of harvest stella coming
to nintendo's switch as a nintendo
switch uh console exclusive on november
4th and before we jump into chapter two
we're actually going to show a quick
video highlighting some of the story
elements from chapter one to get us uh
on our way let's take a look at that
here we see our main character is waking
up we actually find out that they have
amnesia and i'm not sure where they are
so they're welcomed by one of the
residents of the town who kind of
explains the situation to them and then
we're introduced to a sea light for the
first time
and all of a sudden the people in the
town are gathering because oh no a giant
crystal element is falling towards the
earth oh no the planet it's pretty
dangerous
oh when it crashed oh boy but what do we
do when there's a crashed crystal we
investigate it of course
and then while we're investigating it we
actually find someone that we bring back
to our home the mysterious person
and
you know start talking about where they
could be from
and then eventually they run off
which leads us to uh
the person who greet us with our amnesia
are actually showing us the importance
of harvesting and farming and how that
actually plays into the story which
we'll talk a little bit more as we're
going through chapter two
and that's very clear them to give you a
farm so you could have some goals to
work toward as you try to remember who
you are right yeah
so then we're introduced to the canyon
which is just north of our home and we
meet deontas
after speaking with deontas we find out
that we actually have kind of similar
goals and they join our party so we'll
be able to play alongside dances in
chapter two
great that brings us up to speed yeah
we're gonna actually jump into some game
play
yeah and i'm here i just started in my
house i just woke up and i'm about to go
uh farm some crops that i planted the
previous day
um
so let's go check those out and see how
they're doing uh your farm is so cute
amber thank you so much so i planted
some of these dress lettuce and it looks
like they're ready to harvest so i'm
gonna pick all of these
let's go yeah
so yummy there we go and then i also
have some carob seeds so i'm gonna plant
some more seeds too so they're gonna be
ready for the next day
um once i harvest all of these crops and
oh not harvest sorry once i've planted
all these i'm gonna water them oh my god
oh my gosh can we take a look at this
though like
look at how cute this like watering wand
is it's it's so cute and very convenient
very high fantasy very fast too yeah
yeah yeah very efficient i'm loving it i
also love the name of the crops they had
uh carobs i had some carrots yup and i
have some stellar wheat seeds over here
as well all these crops take a little
bit of different time i believe my
carobs will only take one day so i
should be able to pick them tomorrow and
put them in this
chest here or my shipping box and at the
end of the day i'll actually make money
from the things that i put in this chest
so
great perks of farming but it's also
important to note that obviously making
money off of your crops is important
because it allows you to to purchase
things in in the shops in the stores but
you can also use some of the vegetables
that you harvest and the fruit to
cook exactly exactly and so what i'm
going to do right now is i'm going to go
back up to the canyon up here and
go explore a little bit more with
deanthus
try to find my friend but i can also go
and defeat monsters to get seeds so this
is going to help me more with my farming
making sure that i'm still making lots
of money too so i can live this
fantastic farming lifestyle that i need
yeah so as amber said our main goal
right now is to go deeper into the
canyon and find our friend who we're
looking for with dianthus but as you'll
see on the screen time is a very
important part of this game and so when
you start in the morning it's about six
a.m and you know every day you have your
main goals to go forward to but it's a
really good idea to start by harvesting
your crops planting things so at the end
of the day you can go back and see it
and then um you know continue to level
up and get money as you progress with
the game
yeah it's running into some baddies
already
all right took them down with some
defenders yeah
it's important to keep an eye too on
your
health and stamina which you can see in
the bottom left side of the screen the
little yellow bar on the bottom is your
stamina bar and as you perform actions
like farming and even attacking or even
running yeah that uses up some of your
stamina now you have next to that also
you have your little stomach meter and
we mentioned earlier cooking you can you
can make meals for yourself to restore
health and stamina and to fill up that
stomach meter and as long as you have
food in your stomach your stamina will
regenerate automatically
and as amber continues through this area
we're seeing that the map on the top
right actually uh finds the new areas so
everything starts off as black but then
as you explore you see more and more hey
guys i found this really beautiful
waterfall and it's pretty refreshing i
think we should take a break sure we've
already been adventuring we farmed a lot
this morning let's take a little bit of
a break
live your best life i know right
oh and my health and stamina have been
replenished that's great but it did take
some time it did take some time but i
think it's smart to make sure that we're
taking a break every now and then
all right i'm gonna go up this hill area
up here
can we just appreciate how pretty this
place is too it's gorgeous but look at
that i also found a broken ladder up
here
can you fix that ice
let's go try to find the snap from down
here not from down there
i want to i want to get up there
was also another broken ladder over here
that i found previously when i found
deanthus and so
i'm hoping to find that one as well so
we can repair it maybe have some fun
shortcuts throughout this uh
canyon oh here we go
let me talk about dantes for a second i
love the hair her hair is so long and
the shoe the shoes though
she's just fabulous very fabulous so
we found this broken ladder
deanthus is actually going to help me
repair this ladder
so when you are repairing things it's
actually going to also take time
outside of your day to repair um any of
these things so making sure that you're
you have enough time to repair them but
also get back to your house is really
important
so let's see repairing this ladder is
gonna take an
hour
we still have time you do have to keep
an eye on the clock though because if
you're out too late um and you run out
of stamina you'll actually collapse and
be sent back home exactly oh here's
another shiny what's this what is it
what's
a mushroom
all right can you trust the mushroom
that's on the ground i want to eat it it
feels pleasant it smells pleasant yeah
just brush it off what could go wrong
nothing it's like vitamin bitter stuff
[Music]
my stamina okay well good thing i have a
sandwich from my friend chris who can
help me i'm gonna eat this sandwich it's
gonna help uh replenish my health
actually the anthis too oh yes exactly
so it's a good immense so good
that was a good thing
you can see that dianthus is doing more
of those long range attacks yeah
probably because of the high heels you
know but
that's great
let's see what we got all around here i
think you can also see as amber runs
around that she's picking things up off
the side of the road not just an
inedible mushroom but but things like
crafting materials and other ingredients
that you can use in cooking or things
that you can sell
along with your crops to make money yeah
i think she just found some seeds
actually and sometimes some seeds yeah
oh there's so many guys here let's get
them use some of your skills amber i did
i just used one where i was spinning
around but we'll see if i can
[Music]
nice
awesome oh my god uni onion seeds some
copper ore awesome i'm getting lots of
good stuff you are making out like a
bandit oh yeah
what's also helpful is the top right map
has that orange arrow that also points
you in the main objective so it will
help us find our friend that we're
looking for exactly there are a lot of
interesting and important things marked
on the map you can see once you find
them the gathering points where you have
to come back later and continue to find
materials out in the wild
oh
look at that hit there we go that's what
i'm talking about okay great work thank
you thank you you're making this look
easy
oh let the bottle commence yeah get him
deanthus
nice
[Music]
good job i love the scenery and i didn't
talk about it earlier but right now it's
spring and the seasons play a really
important part of the story so what
we're seeing now as we go into summer
fall winter and the quietest and the
season of death uh that will also change
what we're seeing in the colors and
everything as well
got some hard stone
just trying to gather as many resources
as possible i don't know what i want to
make sure i can get everything oh
something
shiny yes shiny oh no we've lost her you
can't eat this though so it's good right
okay i'm gonna reach into the bush and
get this what is this
this is like the most obvious bait
you've ever seen ooh
come on oh no
oh
all right i got him though okay we've
got the hamburger all right let's see
there we go wow
yeah got him no problem got him
that poor goblin i wanted to protect
it's shiny
shiny
all right let's get these guys these
baddies
[Music]
all right
all clear
guys up there oh i know
look at all this more lumber too i'm
getting so many goodies
i can't wait to go back home and uh
plant all these oh and here's this oh
there's a second fridge we're looking
for a ladder yeah oh okay this is gonna
consume one hour
okay
we're getting the important thing about
these ladders is obviously as you can
see these these dungeon areas are quite
large and it does take more than one day
to get through them so being able to
build shortcuts with the ladders like
this helps you progress farther in the
dungeon without wasting as much time
on the areas you've already explored and
i think i just saw on the map that we
were getting kind of close to the next
section of the canyon so maybe since
it's getting late it might be a good
idea to head back yeah and i noticed
that there was a fishing spot here
earlier so i think i might stop and just
fish for just a little bit
i suppose we have
we have time but
and look at how peaceful it is and we
can sit here and listen to the music for
a little bit too
reflect on the adventures from the day
exactly i hope there are fish count all
of our bounties yeah i hope there are
fish
it does take time
can be quite time consuming but you do
get some good stuff from it again things
that you can chip for money or sometimes
things you can use in recipes to make
different types of meals for yourself
and your friends exactly exactly oh come
on fishy fishy please i don't think
they're biting today
maybe we're being a little bit too noisy
maybe i was a little too noisy
let's give another couple seconds and
maybe head back maybe you can't find it
oh there you go awesome okay
oh wow a lot of salmon
nice i love the art the art scheme is so
good all the fish look really cool and
the the meals and the character art
and also this thing that i'm using right
now is a return bell it's something that
i can craft and return immediately to my
farm so if i'm further out in the canyon
than i want to be and i need to return
home quick it's a great item to use to
get back to your home really quickly
um but i'm going to go back outside of
my farm and just
try to
get a few more crops in here right you
did pick up some seeds didn't you yeah i
did i picked up a lot of seeds
um and depending on what you plant it
might be ready tomorrow when you wake up
oh yeah so my carob seeds i think only
take one day so those will be ready for
me tomorrow
and then i can make some more money
but i think we got some uni onion seeds
we got a couple different things so i'd
like to plant those just to make sure
that we have a good uh variety of stuff
so let's let's plant these you need
onion seeds i'm gonna plant them right
in the middle why not
chaos chaos
and then we're gonna surround them with
some duress lettuce because you know
what why not
and then we're gonna bring out our handy
dandy
watering tool i love this watering tool
i know i can't get over it it's so good
i'm just admiring how nice the music is
now that it's nighttime it's so peaceful
and look at how beautiful our farm is
just the aesthetic of this game oh so
pretty gorgeous
well let me just dump all this stuff
into um
into the shipping box we got that
crystal and it looks like it's going to
earn me a lot of money when shipped so
let's send that out
maybe some of these berries
and the fur oh yeah let's ship that fur
all right
and then open up our storage box let's
store some of this stuff because i don't
think i'll need it for a while
yeah
you know onions and things yeah i just
store some stuff
all right just get out of my inventory
all right all right
and now it's getting close to night time
you have time to craft another bell
which is probably a good idea it's a
smart idea just to make sure i have them
yeah
because i know how late you like to be
exploring
how late i like to be up fishing exactly
yeah that's what really happened
and it is good to note also that when
you're crafting at home it also takes
time just a little bit of time yes well
depending on what you make yeah it could
take longer too
awesome yay my return fell so pretty
yeah
hey amber it's almost nine o'clock it's
almost nine o'clock time for bed
all right well let's just take our time
your house is really i know here i'm
just going to do a little
quick pan oh look how cute and homey
this little house is i'm so glad that
they
let us stay here yeah gave us this farm
they're just like here this house is
just here you can take it yeah
oh and you leveled up level up so
running around and beating all those
baddies helped so got some uh physical
tag magic all the good stuff and then
here's our shipment
how much money i made too much
so we can go into town um after i
harvest and of course water some of my
plants
morning chores and my morning chores
exactly but then i'll go back into the
or i'll go into the village and then we
can go look around there and maybe i'm
on a shopping spree yeah yeah let's do
it as long as we just go back and make
sure we find our friend
that's that's the most important thing
for shopping
but first shopping well and you can find
a bunch of interesting things at the
shop you know obviously things for your
farm more seeds but they also have some
equipment that you can use for
adventuring as well so yeah
oh yay my carob seeds are all ready wow
awesome look at all these ready back
there too those are so cute they look
like little bunnies but they do look
like little bunny and tasty
oh and looks like my wheat is also ready
as well
oh
wow i have so much stuff
the chemicals are great too because they
grow quickly they sell for they sell
quite easily yeah but they also give you
a little bit of health and a little bit
of they fill your food meter a little
bit if you're
eating them as a snack while you're out
on the uh on the road
got a lot of uses there ingredients and
in a couple different recipes i think i
have some more wheat seeds so let's
replant these just to make sure that i
still have some stuff growing
gotta maintain this farm
nice thing i think that the stores in
town open at eight a.m yes so i have
enough time in the morning to get my
chores done all right
i think we have some time to grow some
more yeah let's grow some more dressed
lettuce
[Music]
there we go
it's so calming yeah the music on the
farm is just really great nice and
relaxing so peaceful you almost forget
the the imminent danger you're in
exactly
oh all right so let's drop these off in
our shipping box and then we're gonna go
run to the village and i'm gonna sprint
there
there's
oh good thing i got some sandwiches so i
think i'll be fine
that is definitely a play style
[Laughter]
yeah eat everything a sprint everywhere
so this is the village of lethe yes and
i love it's it's so beautiful it's so
pretty it has a sea light in the back
around you can see right there pink
and it's really cool because the first
time i'm introduced to this village
there's no one here and i won't explain
why you know you have to play to find
out but
it's really nice to see it lively with
all the different residents from the
town yeah and there's also a couple
fishing spots in town
but
this is our general store so let's go in
here and see what we can do for our
shopping spree
other places
there are
a smitty where you can upgrade your
weapons and there's a place where you
can get upgrades for your house and your
farm too exactly
and here's oh so we got a fireproof ring
and a defense ring oh oh that's a big
spindle
well you didn't make a lot of money
overnight hello
did you see this backpack over here ten
thousand i i am not rolling in it if
it's a good backpack it's worth it it's
worth it and like our friend crosses
here too
looks like she's buying some stuff as
well
yeah okay as you said too there's a
couple other shops too even the doctor
that you can go visit in the town so
there's a lot of other things too for
you to go do but i really want to make
sure my friend's okay yeah but before
you want to waste too much time yeah
before we do that let's equip this ring
so we already have one ring equipped
yeah i already have one ring equipped
that's a simple magic swordsman ring but
i'm gonna
equip this defense ring i think that'll
help me
while i'm fighting some of these baddies
off to go find your friend yes
come on deanthes let's go
as you can see as she travels on the map
the time actually moves a bit quicker
while you're on the world map so you
have to be very careful and don't be
like me and get all turned around and
waste half a day just trying to find
where you're going next don't do that
don't do that be smart
make good choices
okay it's already 10 30. let's
rush in here and try to find our friend
so you should be able to use those
ladders at your point right exactly
that's what i'll be looking for so
the first one that we repaired
right here
beautiful
that's very very good very convenient
right very convenient very sturdy ladder
these guys are back they don't learn you
are almost out of stamina dear oh i was
running too much do you have any more of
those sandwiches left i do have a lot of
sandwiches
[Music]
oh there we go i'm going to eat one more
now you can well oh look at that that
makes a little bit more full that's true
that's true
your stamina would have regenerated but
it will continue to regenerate longer
now
yeah so once i have my when uh your
stomach is full help replenish some of
that a little bit quicker
[Music]
come on dianthus help me out here's this
back there dances yeah nice job
that's teamwork yeah
[Music]
thank you thank you she's so good
get some more furniture that's a great
ally yeah more copper ore
oh my gosh look at all these baddies god
i love the music in here too
music is so beautiful and it changes
whether you're at your home or in the
village or in the middle of battle it's
all just so different and really cool
come on dientas
there we go i got him
and here is
our other ladder that we went the long
way though i did end up going a long way
i wanted to gather all i wanted to fight
some more guys
well thank you had two sandwiches i i am
thankful i had two sandwiches to do some
little extra little fighting over here
oh and look at all these things berries
blueberry cool that's a cool berry
better than an uncool berry
oh feeling something unusual ahead let's
let's go i hope we can find our friend
[Music]
oh
isn't it beautiful
i love it
that structure i know so
um deanthes and i are going to be
wandering around and we noticed some of
these structures that um
seem a little bit out of place
exactly so
and they shouldn't exist here but it's
all a big mystery a big mystery but
another mystery
speaking of miss speaking of so we also
run into this
magnificent
uh unicorn oh my goodness um he is
looking uh for
a princess
also looking very fly oh he looks very
fly i want his hair
oh and he calls us an impertinent
buffoon
you know just
friendly
very friendly a very friendly guy
rude talking about some princess yes so
he's
this uh corned creature he's looking for
a princess we're also looking for
someone but
he thinks we're hiding the princess from
him or or perhaps hunting the prince or
maybe trying to find her but we're not
hiding her but there's no
we have no convincing him that we are
not hiding
his princess
and we yeah we're also searching for a
girl
he just doesn't want to listen to us at
all
the giant unicorn horn is i know he's
hearing
yeah he he wants to know there's no he's
not he's not going to take any of this
so
witness me
so
he wants to fight me oh no
well
good luck thank you i've never fought a
unicorn before
[Laughter]
come on deanthes let's go
good thing i ate those sandwiches
earlier so my stamina is all good your
health is kind of shaky but oh i think
i'll be fine i got it i got this
oh my goodness oh my gosh hectianthus
danish you got this oh no i watch out
for that ring watch out
okay okay okay all right you're hanging
in there
i won't want to wait for those i want
you to charge back up i know i want my
power
you're almost there though okay really
close where are you
oh no oh no
your skill's ready all right let's get
him
oh oh he got you away yeah
oh there you go i was trying to do the
thousands
but that was a little closer
closer than i thought it would be don't
worry he uh lost love his health right
yeah we beat him
and he's impressed famous last
words witness me
and
look at this beautiful guy oh no oh no i
spoke too soon i'm sorry
well i mean we still have sandwiches
left right i know i have a few
sandwiches uh
yeah so
i'm trembling in his presence so he
still wants to know where his princess
is but
i think if we take some more time to
explain to him
exactly what's going on who we are
looking for that he will
hopefully he'll understand
maybe you can clear up this
misunderstanding let's see
he doesn't seem prone to listen no
and also
the princess and our friend have
different names so i think that's number
one for us to obviously you know they're
not the same person
but let's see if he'll come with us i
think he'd be a a good party member you
know i'd like some healing
think he's a little bit too stingy for
that but oh maybe he might be able to
help us out another way
or maybe he'll just you know be annoying
just just look pretty rude
[Laughter]
helpful somehow yeah somehow maybe we'll
find out we'll find out
ah awesome
so let's go deeper into the camera turn
with us
yeah let's keep looking and try to find
our friend it's only one o'clock so you
got lots of time lots of time
[Music]
the music is so beautiful
oh it's so pretty
so this right here
this is a mono light
these are actually save points um and
teleport points for you so when you go
and activate these um
one obviously you could save your your
progress here which is great but also
you can teleport to different points of
the map but then you could also go back
to your farm so it's another great place
to uh
move and get back home when you need to
if it's getting too late so well and
it's another great way to progress
farther into a dungeon uh exactly
exactly when you have to go home and
sleep there's another fishing spot right
there so many stuff i'm going to go fish
i'm going to say i'm surprising but you
don't use those to find your favorite
fishing spot
you are exhibiting great restraint and i
am i am i'm trying for you guys
[Laughter]
oh what's this a bridge
i'm sure deanthes can help us fix this
[Music]
good old diandis yeah
what's wrong this time
she doesn't have to be happy about it
all right i know
just a little help please just a little
but props to her for fixing that in
those heels oh yeah
um i mean she's making you do it uh i
guess
it's so quick to give her credit
but now we got a repair kit but we also
got a repair kit recipe which i'm
looking forward to to go
make more of these kits and then see
what else i can go repair
it's probably a good idea to have kits
ready before you go on adventures
exactly so you don't get stuck two or
three you know yeah but this one like
the
the ladder previously will take an hour
to repair
um so we're at 2 30 p.m that's fine we
have plenty of time still and let's see
if we can find our friend what is that i
don't know i want to fight it though
different from the other enemies we saw
that monster all right
you're ready
i i am ready i'm ready to jump in let's
go
so this monster dianthus is letting me
know has a thicker hide and so our melee
attacks aren't going to be as useful
against it and we need to use magic if
only we could use magic if only i could
use magic unicorn
that uh you can do it yeah so our
unicorn friend is going to try to teach
us here grumble grumble
please
my magic my please mr unicorn please
crumple crumble
oh come on please
all right very well professor unicorn
class is about to begin you better
listen up let's go
[Music]
fancy wow
now you try it
go ahead yeah just like that
how am i supposed to do that
you can't tell by watching
he's so funny i love his dialogue
[Music]
one mustn't bulk at the first hurdle
amber
[Laughter]
i can do this so you're closing your
eyes now to see if that helps and it
does oh
my magic
oh
i can know
amazing
[Music]
now i can use magic i am really excited
about this mage shop class is one of my
favorites yes
all right
well
let's see what we can do against that
baddie then
[Music]
all right
i want to use my magic yes we can let's
go let's do it let's do this
yeah let's keep moving this
but before i
get going and fighting him i do need to
select this job really quick you can
normally do this on a monolith or you
can only do this on a monolith but
just for tutorial purposes it's allowing
me to
change the mage class right now
all right so
we're changing
to the mage look at how i
oh my goodness
that was extremely effective extremely
wow yeah
we're so strong guys check that out oh i
just yeah i love it
magic
so i know we have to go further into the
canyon to find our friend but uh it's
almost three o'clock so maybe we should
call it a day for now yeah i think so
too because i also got more stuff to go
uh
plant
water yeah everything i get those carobs
and you gotta spend some time fishing
let's be honest
i mean i didn't want to say it but
and with that i'm actually gonna use my
return bell here to go back home
[Music]
awesome safe and sound safe and sound
exactly great um so we'll actually stop
there for today but before we end um we
actually have a special video from
goshina who's the composer of harvest
stella so let's take a look at that
harvest
[Music]
all right so that's all the time we have
today to show you harvestello we hope
you enjoyed what we had to show
um the game is available for pre-order
now on nintendo eshop and it will
release on november 4th i hope you're
all looking forward to it as much as we
are
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
next time
[Music]
you